I remember as a kid he would you know
have me come sit next to him and Cheryl
Burke reveals she was sexually abused as
a child a lot of the physical stuff
happened like in his van when he would
pick me up from school a billy riot
after school the former Dancing with the
Stars Pro opened up in TLC's documentary
breaking the silence it aired Sunday
night Burke revealed that her mother
asked a family friend to watch Cheryl
when she was just in kindergarten the
man was in his 60s and he abused Cheryl
the man was later caught trying to
molest another child and Burke testified
against him when she was just six he was
sentenced to 20 years in prison but
Cheryl says the abuse drove her to a few
bad relationships when she got older
once I got sexually molested and abuse I
think my way of craving his attention
would be dating men kind of like him
thinking that that's how I should be
treated because in a way that's how I
was raised
Burke says dancing was the quote escape
from reality
she needed I'm proof that you can
actually move on from this